[Music]  next season on America's Got Talent  this year season 13 people coming from  farther away they're younger they're  older they're you know doing crazier  stunts every year when you think you've  seen everything you realize you ain't  seen nothing and it doesn't always go  according to plan as these brothers from  Spain find out tonight they actually did  better than how we did when our  interview got interrupted  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Applause]  how do you keep it fresh every year how  do you keep people wanting to tune in  sound of the drop Awards are falling on  the surface of water I mean the wind  they produce the show it's like a mini  movie every episode I love watching the  show  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]